worst thing you can do for your skin is
go tanning not only do they cause skin
cancer but they also accelerate aging
rapidly hi i'm dr maniv shah and this is
skin support
[Music]
so at young forehead great username
should you or shouldn't you pop your
pimples i'm trying to settle a debate
all right let's settle this debate right
now anyone who follows me knows i am
very much against popping your pimples
they can lead to infections it can lead
to scarring we have to think about what
causes the pimple or where is the pimple
in your skin in general it's actually
stuck inside your hair follicle unit or
basically inside your pore so this
pimple is a little pus ball filled and
stuck inside this pore now it's
restrained there which is fine it's not
going to cause any scarring at this
point the second that you pop it you
actually rupture that hair follicle and
it damages the surrounding collagen
because of all that inflammation so
that's where you get scarring so
definitely don't pop your pimples if you
don't want scarring if you don't want
that post-inflammatory hyperpigmentation
that sticks around forever there are so
many good spot treatments out nowadays
that eliminate your pimples pretty
quickly without you having to pop them
magumbo ink asked why is there no cure
for hair loss i wish there was because
everybody including myself suffers from
hair loss we don't have an answer yet
hopefully one day in my lifetime we will
have an answer but all of our cells go
through basically a programmed death
cycle they can only live so long they're
all meant to replicate a certain amount
of times and then eventually die off and
our hair cells are exactly the same way
and once they die off you really can't
get them back and so we have treatments
in dermatology that can actually stop
the hair loss process slow the hair loss
process maybe get you a few hairs back
but nothing that's a complete cure at
this time hopefully one day we do but if
we ever have a cell that were to
continue to replicate forever and ever
and never die off that's exactly what
cancer cells do so we don't necessarily
want that we need to find something in
between that lasts long enough that we
can produce hair shafts forever but not
last long enough that it turns into a
cancer
rocking it for you asked how safe for
tanning booths i used to go tanning all
the time as a result of that i ended up
developing skin cancer at the age of 31
when nobody in my family has ever had
skin cancer and i went tanning probably
over 100 times so we know the tanning
booths are going to increase your risk
of skin cancer we know that it's going
to accelerate aging as a matter of fact
you have uvb radiation and you have uva
radiation now uvb radiation uvb b stands
for bad that's the one that damages your
dna and mostly causes skin cancer and
then uva mostly causes aging well our
tanning booths are actually mostly uva
so not only do they cause skin cancer
but they also accelerate aging rapidly
so that's why people that use tanning
beds often look much older than their
age and so they're not safe they
increase the risk of skin cancer and if
there's one thing that i do on all my
social media platforms and when i get on
here and i talk to all of you is the
worst thing you can do for your skin is
go tanning cujo pd asked hey siri how do
i get rid of genital warts probably not
tweeting to everybody about your genital
warts would be a good start uh genital
warts are actually caused by the hpv or
human papilloma virus and that human
papilloma virus can cause cervical
cancer in women and it can also cause
penile cancer in men if you do have
genital warts that's something you want
to get treated and it's also something
that you don't want to spread to other
people especially your partner who could
end up with cervical or penile or anal
cancer as a result of that but once you
have it we do have several ways to get
rid of it including freezing them with
liquid nitrogen and using other topical
treatments like amiguamod which is a
prescription medication and others that
can get rid of them but i would have
them treated and not try to spread them
to other people but you have different
types of hpv vaccines that are very
effective at stopping you from getting
this in the first place now the hpv
vaccine is approved up to 45 but it
probably has even benefit beyond that
there's actually a new study that showed
that up to 87 percent reduction in
cervical cancer in women so it actually
makes a huge difference if you get it
and i actually recommend it highly to
people especially at a young age to
prevent getting hpv in the first place
next up dr che had asked how the heck
does accutane work goodness gracious so
accutane is actually no longer on the
market but i actually use that word
still myself it's actually known as
isotretinoin so isotretinoin is a
vitamin a derivative but to understand
how it works we have to go back to what
causes acne in the first place so
there's a few things that cause acne one
your skin cells basically stick together
too much and basically clog your pores
two you have bacteria that's stuck in
those pores clogging those pores three
you have increased oil production that's
trapped inside your pores and four all
of that bundle creates inflammation so
basically four main things that causes
acne accutane or isotretinoin targets
three out of those four very very
effectively it decreases oil production
decreases skin cell stickiness and
decreases inflammation and is the number
one best treatment for acne the problem
is that it does have some side effects
that we do need to monitor so it's not
for everyone it's not the answer for
everyone's acne but for people with
really bad nodular cystic or scarring
acne it is an absolute obliterating
medication and life-changing medication
for people that have acne next up we
have gigi rimmon why does my skin break
out when i have stress as if that won't
stress me out more ah this is such a
good question so
when you have stress physiologically it
actually causes you to break out this is
actually something that's really well
documented we have a hormone released
from our hypothalamus called
corticotropin releasing hormone and it
actually acts on the sebaceous or sweat
or oil glands within the hair follicles
that actually causes acne so that stress
hormone acts on your hair follicle to
create the oil that causes acne that's
like the worst thing ever right because
you get stressed you break out you're
stressed out more because now you have
acne and it's just a vicious cycle and
you can actually get in your own head
and make your acne worse this is
actually true for hair loss too that
stress can cause hair loss or telogen
effluvium and you can end up in this
vicious cycle where your stress is
actually making your hair loss worse i
could just tell you like don't be
stressed but i'm stressed myself so i
don't really have a good answer for you
but you know some meditation in the
morning you know exercising can really
get your mind off things and just stick
with a regimen that works for acne and
then that will help to improve it but i
can't eliminate all stress in life i
wish i could
mini pulley me asked while we're talking
about stuff like this is antiperspirant
more dangerous than deodorant so good
question and a lot of people just
consider these two to be the same thing
but they're actually very different so
antiperspirants actually block equine
sweat from happening so they basically
occlude those ducts the other side you
have deodorant which actually doesn't do
that it just is basically perfume
essentially for your armpits deodorants
in general are gonna be considered to be
safer because there is some risk that
people speak of regarded aluminum if you
talk to most dermatologists and most
people in the scientific space they'll
tell you that that risk is unfounded so
there is some concern that aluminum can
cause cancer right now that's unfounded
so we definitely need more data now if
you're someone who's concerned about
this i think it's reasonable to just use
deodorant now personally from my
personal opinion it's not something that
i'm worried about i always make my
recommendations based on what i would
recommend to my mom my sister my dad my
wife based on my recommendations to my
own family members i'm not currently
worried about antiperspirants or
aluminum-based deodorants that may
change as more data comes out but if you
are somebody who's concerned i think it
would be reasonable to use deodorant
that doesn't have the aluminum in it so
sunshine r kayla asked okay i have a
question skincare friends i've been
having issues pretty consistently with
breaking out on my cheeks just the lower
part i haven't changed anything in my
skincare routine but it's frustrating so
this is a really good and common
question hormonal acne can affect any
part of the face but specifically we
find that in women specifically in their
20s and 30s outside of those teenage
years seem to develop acne along the
jawline we don't necessarily know why
this happens some people think it has to
do with different receptors in the skin
at these levels but we do know that
people get hormonal acne specifically in
this region the treatment over the
counter is going to be identical so
you're going to look for those acne
fighting ingredients salicylic acid
benzyl peroxide adaptolene or retinoids
that's all you can do for it over the
counter it's when you see a
dermatologist that we're going to treat
your hormonal acne different then we
would treat other forms of acne so what
we would essentially do is go after the
hormones instead of going after other
things that we usually treat acne with
we instead go after the actual hormones
and we give medications that regulate or
normalize your hormone production to get
you back into balance
so room aesthetics asked why does skin
wrinkle with age you have to think about
volume so you have to picture yourself
essentially as a grape so when you're
young you're a grape when you get older
you start to lose volume your volume
starts to head in the direction of
gravity and you develop wrinkles or you
become essentially a raisin and the
number two thing is movement now you
have to picture yourself as a leather
shoe when you get a brand new leather
shoe it's got no creases in it but as
soon as you start to move and walk it
develops essentially a crease in it and
that's what happens when we move the
muscles in our face you develop wrinkles
because of that so it's volume and
movement and basically all the
treatments that we have in dermatology
aesthetics plastic surgery actually
target one of these two things to
eliminate wrinkles you got to ask
yourself hey is this anti-aging cream
actually gonna work for me it has to
target one of these things it either has
to stop movement which we don't really
have any topical treatments that can
really do that effectively there is a
topical treatment called argireline that
may have some benefits similar to botox
to stop movement but beyond that we're
thinking about how do we restore volume
so the first thing you can do is protect
your volume so one thing is to actually
wear sunscreen we know that about 90 of
the aging that happens to our skin is
actually due to the sun and so by
inhibiting the sun effect on the skin by
using sunscreen that's going to do most
of the work the other thing is you could
try to build the volume that you lost by
building the collagen and support
structures in your skin the number one
thing for that as far as topical creams
is going to be your retinols or vitamin
a derivatives smart solarium uk asked
how dangerous is sunburn can one case of
severe sunburn give you cancer
so sadly yes in a way because the way
that skin cancers are formed is
basically a mutation in your dna must
occur and that dna mutation leads to
rapid replication of one cell so you
really only have to get one bad cell for
this all to happen and so a really bad
sunburn could damage your dna to the
point where you get an abnormal cell
that does turn into a skin cancer now
that is relatively uncommon but we do
know that just a single sunburn during
childhood can increase your risk of skin
cancer by 50
anytime you get more sunburns it's going
to be even worse for you so not just
melanomas but you can also get squamous
cell skin cancers basal cell skin
cancers you can't reverse what you did
in the past so you can't go back in time
and stop your sunburns but what you can
do going forward is wear sunscreen every
day and really try to get shade when
you're out in the sun at the beach
coffeeologist asked what is the optimal
spf that i should use on my face right
now i have spf 15 but i'm not sure if
it's protective enough perfect segway
here so this is a common misconception
because the fda actually recommends spf
15. spf 15 blocks about 93 of uvb
radiation we find that that's really not
enough in dermatology because people
don't really apply it thick enough as
they're supposed to from the american
academy of dermatology we really
recommend spf 30 or higher you don't
need spf 100 but spf 30 to spf 60 is
really going to get you there spf 15 is
probably not enough when you get to spf
30 you get 97 coverage if you use thick
enough of a layer
jungle oh gop asked sos help i got a
piercing around a month ago and i've
developed an infection in the area
what do i do crying face so this is july
15th so i'm hoping they're okay it's
been a while hopefully they saw somebody
um any type of infection if it's
starting to spread or become painful or
draining pus definitely see a doctor for
this probably don't tweet unless the
people tweeting back at you or saying to
go see a doctor one of the things that
you can do is just clean the area with
soap and water clean the area with
alcohol chlorhexidine or iodine any
wound those are the best things to
really clean it with so you can use a
topical antibiotic ointment polysporin
is a good option especially in the
united states clean the area with soap
and water if it really starts to get
worse and you start to have fevers
chills headaches or start to feel really
ill that's when you want to see a doctor
kc2sjm asked fact or crap wind burn can
be more dangerous and last longer than a
sunburn is this a fact or is it crap
specifically when you talk about wind
burn or sunburn this is actually a great
debate in the dermatology community
there are some dermatologists that don't
even think wind burn exists they
actually think that wind burn is
actually just sunburn disguised as
being in the cold windy times my opinion
is a combination of both when it's windy
and cold outside the humidity is down
wind is blowing in your face your skin
starts to crack and get dry and it
weakens your skin barrier and this makes
you more sensitive to the sun because
now that top layer of your skin can't
protect you from the sun so it's a
combination
wind low humidity plus the sun that
actually causes wind burn the sunburn is
actually more dangerous because it's
damaging your dna and the wind burn may
last longer because it just takes you
longer for your skin to heal so it's a
combination of the two actually guinot
sw18 asks does your skin breathe and
does it need to detox some people will
say hey my skin's breaking out i need to
give it a chance to breathe what the
people are experiencing in that
situation is that a lot of times their
skin care products or makeup is actually
making their skin worse they're using
products that are clogging their pores
or they're using products that are
actually irritating their skin and by
giving their skin a chance to quote
unquote breathe their skin may get
better as a result of that so no your
skin doesn't physiologically breathe but
giving your skin a breather from harsh
products that are damaging your skin
barrier may actually be beneficial for
some people and we need to sweat because
it eliminates heat from our body it
regulates our electrolyte productions in
our body but we don't necessarily need
to remove toxins from our skin our
kidneys and our liver do most of the job
doing that our skin does very little job
to detox our bodies our welsh makeup
asked skin care question does anyone
know why some moisturizers make my face
feel sweaty a few seconds after applying
it like not just a moisture layer but
like i've been sweating
when you're applying a moisturizer
you're basically applying like a blanket
to your face and that increased heat or
suffocation of the skin could
essentially cause you to sweat a little
bit more moisturizers actually prevent
water loss that's the main mechanism by
which they work so if you start sweating
and you apply a moisturizer it's going
to trap that moisture that's coming out
of your pores right into the skin and so
you may actually be locking in your
sweat and just feeling a little bit more
than you probably normally would
next up we have ted talk ideas and if
they're supposed to last forever how
does tattoo removal work what ends up
happening with tattoo is that you're
putting an ink underneath the skin
essentially into the dermis layer of the
skin and it basically sits there and
that's what we see when we look at
underneath the microscope we see these
little particles of black or red dots
sitting in that dermis layer of the skin
we used to think that tattoos would last
forever but then they invented laser
tattoo removal how does it work is
basically there's a specific laser beam
that targets what we call a chromophore
now chromophore is anything that absorbs
light at a specific wavelength if you
have black tattoo ink the laser will
target that specific black tattoo ink
and really nothing else and that's the
chromophore that it's attacking and by
hitting that with high power energy
laser beam essentially explodes these
into tiny little particles that your
body's able to finally absorb and get
rid of amelia chan asked why does my
sister have asian flush but i don't
you're luckier than your sister i
suppose but it certainly is genetic to
some degree so what ends up happening
with asian flush or alcohol flush they
drink alcohol and immediately they turn
beet red and it's actually kind of
painful for them it's very very
uncomfortable so alcohol needs to be
converted and metabolized to basically
the inactive forms of it but what ends
up happening is people with asian flush
they have a mutation in their acetyl
aldehyde dehydrogenase gene and that
mutation makes it so that they can't
break down acetylaldehyde so alcohol is
you drink the alcohol it's converted to
acetylaldehyde and then they're not able
to break it down that acetyl aldehyde
builds up in the body it causes tons of
inflammation flushing redness pain
throbbing sensation and actually people
with a mutation in this particular
enzyme or gene or increased risk of
esophageal cancer when they drink
because this acetyl aldehyde is actually
really toxic to cells it's actually
physiologically a dangerous thing to
have asian flush and drink on at the
same time so it doesn't exclusively
affect the asian populations it happens
to be more common in the asian
populations because it's passed through
essentially mitochondrial dna which is
passed actually from the mom usually
you inherit your mitochondrial dna from
and so it is genetic it can happen in
all populations it just happens to be
more common in the asian population next
up jonathan asked curious how you can
spot skin cancer what does it look like
and are there any symptoms like i was
saying earlier skin cancer can kind of
look like anything but the main thing
that i would really want to warn
everybody about is something called
melanoma which is basically when a mole
becomes abnormal and that's one of those
dark or brown looking moles we actually
do have a really helpful mnemonic for
this and we call that the abcdes of
melanoma a stands for asymmetry so if
you were to take a mole and you were to
lay it over on top of itself it was if
it was asymmetric that would be one sign
that it's not good b means basically the
borders are jagged or abnormal c means
that it has more than one color so it's
not just one homogeneous same color
brown but there's specks of black
there's specks of brown there's specks
of pinks that's abnormal you don't want
that either d stands for diameter
anything over six millimeters or the
size of like a pencil head eraser head
that's concerning as well and the last
thing is e or evolving so any mole
that's changing growing bleeding all of
a sudden doesn't look the same as it did
before that's something to look for and
the last thing is actually become
recently recognized in the literature
what we call the ugly duckling sign so
basically it's when you have one mole
that just doesn't look like the rest of
the moles on your body if you have any
of those signs or symptoms you want to
see a dermatologist immediately the
depth of how deep that mold goes can be
life-changing if it goes too deep it
could have already spread if it's very
shallow then we may be able to just
remove it right in the office so not
something to wait on everything else you
can wait on if you have a pimple what
have you but if you have an abnormal or
changing mole that's not something you
want to wait on
libby asked can your lips get sunburned
something about lip gloss at the beach
seems dangerous you certainly can get
sunburned on your lips as a matter of
fact your risk of sunburn on your lips
is actually higher than the rest of your
skin because it doesn't have that
protective top layer of the skin called
the stratum corneum so it doesn't have
as much protecting it as the rest of
your body does and we do see skin
cancers on the lips and when we remove
them it can actually affect the function
of your mouth and so a lot of people
don't even think to put sunscreen on
your lips but when you're at the beach
especially if you're prone to getting
sunburned you should really actually put
on a sunscreen lip balm next up ex
tinabee bb asked hen dermatology twitter
give me some good skincare racks wearing
an n95 all day has my skin breaking out
and it's already a little oily at
baseline sos yeah this is a big problem
that i saw throughout the year is just
mask related issues and that a lot of
people contributed it to mask acne
specifically but there was this other
side of the coin that was mask
irritation so just having that mask on
your skin all day rubbing up against
your face and also trapping moisture on
your face was actually really irritating
the skin so there's basically two
different piles you can choose from if
you have true acne and where your pores
are clogged and you have inflammatory
bumps on the skin i highly recommend not
wearing makeup underneath your mask wear
nothing under the mask that's actually
going to clog your pores because if you
do it's actually going to make acne
worse another thing is you didn't have
acne before so you may consider adding
an acne treatment to your routine so
something like adaptolene or salicylic
acid or benzoyl peroxide those are going
to be your three top ingredients for
treating acne over the counter consider
adding one of them not all of them
because that can make irritation worse
now if you have irritation to the skin
you're going to want to change your mask
out frequently use softer masks maybe
use fabric masks you know change up that
regimen and then overnight moisturize
use zinc oxide paste that help to repair
the skin barrier so two different camps
you have to pick which camp you're in
and then target the treatment at that
redbeard lull asked i have a pretty bad
cracked heel from the bad skin
should i go to a foot doctor
or a dermatologist this is a good
question because in medicine we always
look at okay you have the heart doctor
and they deal with the heart and then
you have the kidney doctor and they deal
with the kidney when truly our bodies
are all one piece right so you have to
really look at it from a holistic
approach so you definitely have
overlapping fields and so when it comes
to foot care dermatology and podiatry
definitely overlap so your foot doctor
is your podiatrist i would prefer that
you would see your podiatrist because
i'm personally not not interested in
seeing everyone's feet we definitely
treat foot conditions and dermatology
especially cracked feet you can
definitely see a podiatrist will both
treat you probably equally as well one
of the things that i highly recommend
for anybody that has that cracked dry
feet so anything that has ammonium
lactate or urea in it very effective at
moisturizing and also exfoliating that
thickened cracked heel
all right that wraps it up i hope you
learned something i know i learned
something from all of your questions if
you have more questions make sure to hit
twitter and we'll see you next time